[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm Lincoln I'm
Rhett it's time for another conversation
with someone interesting from the
internet and this week that person is
Thomas Ridgewell aka Tom Scott
yep Tom first became known for his
co-authorship and voice-over work on the
popular animated series online eddsworld
and also way back in 2006 he started his
own YouTube channel TomSka basically
sketch comedy animations and action
videos we've been huge fans of time we
were a lady to find out that he knew of
our work from way back in the day so it
was really cool to catch up with him at
VidCon to have this conversation his
channel is approaching three million
subscribers he's got over 525 million
views and he's updating his content
regularly showcasing his distinct sense
of humor here's a little sample of his
work in this sketch picture-perfect
released in November 2013 it's got about
two million views in this Tom attempts
to teach his fellow youtuber crabstickz
how to paint Chris I'm gonna teach you
how to paint why because I want to build
the only type of ship that doesn't sink
the Titanic no a friendship also the
Titanic did sink impossible Chris I want
you to paint me done show me that is a
shoe you have painted a shoe it must be
this brush try again done sure me
imagined you being Chinese this time
that is still a shoe yet somehow more
racist Dan this senate phobic brush only
a bad workman blames his tools why not a
work woman now is not the time for
feminism Chris when will it be time Tom
try again
Tom's most popular series is his
asdfmovie as de fée series flash
animation that consists of rapid-fire
short skits featuring various stick
figures having quick dialogue exchange
Eggers figures figures as eye figures
figures emphasis on the GU er the
assitive series as a whole which has
seven episodes in ancillary content has
just over 290 million views almost 300
million views on this stuff here's a
taste of episodes
seven ma'am I'm afraid I caught your son
doing homework no thanks mr. muffin but
I want a guy hey Stacy do you want to go
to the prom with me I'm sorry but I'm a
ghost but you're not dead by Brian okay
you get you get an idea pretty random
stuff but hilarious now I really enjoyed
this conversation with Tom I feel like
this was a very honest very poignant
conversation with him yeah I mean I say
this is one of my favorite ear biscuits
thought-provoking poignant did you say
poignant I did say poignant did you did
you say the G did you pronounce the
poignant I could say poignant if you
want me to you could say that if not
good say figure yeah we talked to Tom
about the interesting ramifications of
his upbringing as a Jehovah's Witness
and his path to agnosticism we also
talked about what business he has making
a bona fide sex education video on his
channel he did just that and we had an
extremely open discussion about him
losing his best friend and creative
partner ed Gould creator of eddsworld to
leukemia in March of 2012 yeah I mean I
think in our conversation the way he put
it back to us was he asked us what would
it be like if one of us lost the other
how would we carry on personally and
creatively so I really appreciated the
fact that Tom went there with us any
open we had a conversation about that
painful part of his life and and and how
he's continuing to deal with that here
it is our ear biscuit with TomSka
[Music]
do you live life at the pace of asdf
movies make you say it both ways you
don't care I don't mind how you say it
of okay it's um but usually has to I say
asked if because in my naive little mind
I was like everyone will figure that out
but it was very wrong people say STF and
I really hated that for a while then I
realize actually no that making it
easier to share because they're seeing
how to spell it to people so no I
appreciate these people but do I live my
life at that pace because there's like a
it's a breakneck pace like joke joke
joke I'm in and out to the next thing to
the next thing
yeah is that how your brain or your life
works just definitely how my brain works
and that's really exciting in my life
not so much my life is a lot of sleeping
just touched a lot of it you know for me
a very successful day is a day where I
come up with one joke but to put it in
perspective the speed of my brain and my
life has changed so much that I made one
joke that's in one of my asked of movies
hey check out my new camera bang oh wait
this isn't a camera that was like the
first animation I ever made back in
about 2004 and it was a minute and a
half long same joke 1jo same drug
three-second long joke it took a minute
and a half to tell and now you know ten
years later there what in the ivory made
it you know it's it's three seconds long
and that's just that it's just my
comedic timing has condensed fun in fact
though I put that that was my first ever
animation went live on Smosh com long
long before YouTube really before they
yeah like that's yeah I've been around
since way before YouTube that's it's
just YouTube happened and that was
lovely it was like how did you know calm
how did Smosh calm Ian and Anthony
created it before YouTube yeah but it
was just for their friends cuz we talked
to him about it yeah how did you get on
that I've been in the I've been in the
scene I've been in the game of really
long time I was but were you like you
were on their forums as a user and you
submitted videos and and I wish I could
find them now I guess that's the only
place I know I uploaded it but it's I
think it's long gone but I had a history
of getting banned off forums for being a
disagreeable twelve-year-old but oh you
got kicked off a smashing I got kicked
off everything absolutely everything but
like by being belligerent and in the
forum just being very 12 you know you're
average you know
twelve-year-old halo playing I slept
with your mother last night kind of
attitude that was that was me entirely
so when I'm it and lately I'm going
through this kind of wave of really
wanting to encourage people to not be
awful that's purely because I was so
awful and I see that in my own audience
I'm like I think you guys are a lot like
me and and and if you are then no please
don't be like me but you know I was I
was on I was on smart come ages ago and
and what did that look like did that
look terrible asmath it looked pretty
yet doesn't like no this style was a
stickman animation this is all you the
time yeah yeah this was back when I
didn't know how to animate oh I don't
know how to animate now I just hire
people who have way better than me right
so you write and direct everything and
you've got animators yeah I wanted to be
a voice talent I wanted to be an
animator originally but I just didn't
have the patience for it but I yeah I
write I direct undirected couple kind of
you throw a quote saying when it comes
to animation because really it's so much
down to the creative genius of the
animators you're working with but but
you do a lot of different things yes I
don't like doing the same thing too many
times but so as DIF ones are the you
know the far and away the most
successful on your chance it's a lot of
really successful stuff there by the way
but you put out number seven just a few
weeks ago and it's the anunciar and it's
a month it's already gotten up to
fourteen million years or fifteen
million it's just like all the other
ones
yeah and that's and that's that's that's
really lovely and that's such a
comforting thing like I figured if I
uploaded one of those and it doesn't
work then either decides change so I'm
just not funny anymore either
you describe them I describe that series
specifically as yeah quickfire animated
sketches very Americanized I think
really when I began I did a lot of
American accents now I'm trying to do
mostly British accents because you know
I used to market upon a for me I always
find American accents funnier with with
call me like like like swear words are
so much funnier when said with American
accents and British accents in my
opinion but I think Americans would beg
to differ but for me right did you
personally from Yorba I think the f-word
went set by Americans sort of funny
really well it's not one of those words
that changes a lot somehow somehow it
just sounds perfect when it comes out of
my number
American you'll basically engineer these
things to be the Quickfire now so how is
that kind of jokes at their absolute
course or any joke and any any joke any
narrative you can tell you know a dozen
different ways you can tell it over the
course of an hour or over a minute or I
think you can condense any narrative
into about three seconds at its core and
some others it's some of them completely
random like well there's the this one's
not random but it's the this the Sun and
then there's a planet orbiting on the
Sun and it just says you're fat yeah and
you're out that's it that's it there's
no setup even it's no that's just fine
it's completely minimal it's it the
whole point is that I try to take
absolutely I even know why that's funny
sometimes it's just I'm just like I just
know it is it just yeah you don't need
to explain it yeah actually being that
quick you know may be a question it made
it funnier yeah you know it was funny
period but then because it was funny and
it was over it became even funny
surprised why did that happen yeah you
just did just wait what and it's just
this confusion yin and yet cuz comedy is
core is the subversion of expectations
yeah and sometimes just the lack of a
joke is funny yeah well I I thought
something was gonna happen but it didn't
happen I'm laughing or something so
random like that what was the feather
joke oh hey baby you allergic to
feathers no hey baby you ain't know it's
two guys in it set it up two guys in a
bar there's a there's a there's a man
and he slides up to a woman at a bar and
he says hey baby are you an angel
because I'm allergic to feathers and
then he throws up on her like he's
violently so yeah like that's like the
way a lot of jokes get rain is you're
out that's it yeah that's it but a lot
of jokes I write come from like here's a
thing that here's a trope here's a
catchphrase a cliche how can I just
break it which is pretty standard but
yeah so it's like hey hey baby are you
an angel why did you do the hug from you
when you have flow from having that kind
of stuff and for then I was like what if
it's like allergies related because it
originally it was a comic that I read
when I was 16 where the loss panel is
just he's just broken out with his face
is just inflated because he's having a
Ledge reaction but well you know I've
changed him throwing up to make it more
appealing and then quick fire and
explosive right in the way that the
vomit looked it was like as tall as his
head and as straight as an arrow chunk
size moments
reject I'll now I'm tempted to you know
to come up with some analogy or some
reason you know for why that content
works so well like oh well the mindset
of today's youth is just so fragmented
all over the place and so your frenetic
Gigi
yeah and kids don't need a story anymore
they just need a stream of jokes and Tom
Scott is proving it ruining the youth of
tomorrow honestly I think it's a very
simple analysis as far as I'm concerned
it's incredibly funny the jokes are
really really funny and it's just you're
like that was funny that was funny that
was funny
that was funny and it just after a while
there's just this overwhelming like how
are almost funny yeah I think that's a
good lesson good what did I say over no
I'm a green you use the word
overwhelming I said like over warming or
something that word that yes I'm also
contributing to global warming but yeah
it's just a cavalcade of everything
being so funny and there's no duds kind
of a thing is experience agree entirely
for everyone I put out and I'm sure
there's about three that I go why did I
do that what I've seen with even within
a video there's always about three that
get made you know within the loss like
two days of production oh my goose was
funny at the time and I look back and
I'm like that's awful that's that's not
a joke but then other people like them
and I just kinda have to go like okay
but I have very high it you wouldn't
guess it but I do have very high
standards of what what doesn't what does
not go in because it's not just random I
think one of the things that I've
observed about it is I think a lot of
people see certain content that might be
popular today like what you're creating
and they're just like oh it's just
random and people just like random stuff
and so it's like you know we could just
throw a bunch of words and characters
into a blender and mix it up and the
kids will love it it's like no I you
know we I want to give art this
generation more credit than most people
really make the fact that they like what
you're doing that encourages me as a
comedian oh wow
well ya know III don't I absolutely
disagree when when people do say that
you know it's just like this this
mindless comedy and just like kids today
are stupid dumb yeah I do have I do have
a lot more faith in them
I just think that people do typically
outgrow the animations over time I've
witnessed you know you know I've been
doing them for long enough now that I've
witnessed a generational shift you know
naughties kids started watching them and
now they're teenies kids we all really
have a name for these two decades do we
not season teenies yeah cuz then it's
the 20s 30s 40s oh I came in right now
right yeah well for fun our C's is 90s
right no that no there's a 90s then
there's the naughties no the Nazis are
the zeros right yeah like the jess2010
yeah right I'm all right yes cuz we
don't use the term not for zero I mean
so when they say Conte's I just think
about naughty things we've done naughty
things yeah this took a time thing is
like thinking people people grow up and
suddenly they become way more analytical
if the things I laughing it and they
kind of I want to say hi they get high
standards but in a way it's more they
just they don't they've won whereas when
you're a kid you you so desperately want
to be entertained like you will read the
back of a cereal box for like just gonna
read this and maybe something will be
interesting on it you you know you
definitely want anything to be funny
anything to be interesting and you'll
just laugh at anything when you when you
kind of you hit this cynicism when
you're about 18 years you get
self-confidence suddenly you're just
like I know Here I am you be funny and I
will dissect you and I will run you
through your paces and a lot of kids
decide that they're no longer gonna find
what I do funny and that's kind of
understandable because I you know I I
obviously have that with a lot of you
she was that I watch no I was a huge fan
of Smosh growing up but you know I think
now I've kind of reached a point where
it's like they're still entertaining the
same kind of demographic and I have
growing it's not absolutely not that job
to to grow with me they've got their
thing and that's that's great but it's
yeah it's no longer my thing and I think
a lot of kids do grow out of it hmm
something you enjoy at the start and
it's a lot of fun some people still have
fun with it and that's great and I and I
love meeting those people it's strange
when they invite me to their weddings
and name their kids after me that's
happened one child it has the middle
name of TomSka which is bizarre the
whole middle name is name is Thomas go
OK telling about the S is capitalized
how does this work I have no idea
someone just came up to me one day and
and said oh yeah my--like my sister
named her child his middle name is Tom
scar
and then she was off into the night and
I'm still left wondering if that was
true and you've seen no pictures I've
seen no birth certificate but I'm gonna
take her word for it we've had we've had
pets named after us people who have like
two cats maybe some sort of child
support I hope no I think you're at risk
probably not mine I mean but yeah the
whole game franchise that's true but I
mean an entire human at least middle
name that for you you know I don't know
how much that counts sometimes people
have named Tom after me that's very
presumptuous yeah right there's a lot of
times very popular well it's interesting
you talk about your fans out growing
your content and you're just backfilling
with younger fans I guess is what you're
saying and because they get more
analytical or they start to look down on
maybe the just the tone of it but I
think he's that he his content has grown
down I kind of I think it's I think it's
very common for all of us to throw what
we used to love under the bus like oh
that's good stuff no I don't like that
and then yeah when we then we hit our
20s and we're like oh maybe I shouldn't
been so hard in it but then sometimes we
don't make that realization so are you
this angsty teenage phase where it's
like all those things that you used to
love you're like oh this is lame now I
would never know I'm not just no you
know what you're saying your work is is
aging up as you get older and as your
comedic
tastes change that's what you're saying
do both you know like you've got my my
animations like a stop maybe which stays
a kind of a constant level and when I
make that I am making it for myself
aged 12 to 15 that's who I know would
like that video and I'm gonna keep
aiming for that specific kid turns out
there are a lot of that kid out there in
the world which is weird because I don't
have any friends when I was that age so
I wish I could've met any of these guys
yeah these like these like adventure
these Adventure Time invader zim loving
catchphrase screaming pie is the
funniest thing in the world
haha cheese kids it's right I guess
that's what I was that's absolutely who
I was and yeah you're still targeting
that but you've got other things you're
saying like basically basically
everything I make is is for me at a
different age that's kind of how I
figure it so
you know I do like the estimate was yeah
that that's for me at certain ages but
then I do the action videos and that's
kind of more when I was what I was
looking for when I was eighteen nineteen
when I was very until you know Freddie
Wong in that and and not that I'm not
still into Freddie Wong in a romantic
way but but yeah I mean and i even did
you know i did a video called the sex
talk which was aimed at must again
myself aged kind of more around fourteen
because I never got the sex talk and and
and so I was like I needed to have seen
this yeah awful lesser like so hopefully
other kids well okay so that's your
motivation because we were just talking
about that it's interesting because
someone sure of your work is just strict
to comedy now not that the sex talk
wasn't funny and at its moments but I
thought okay when I sit down and watch
that video this might be a parody but
then I'm like oh no there's no penis and
that's how it works it's not even got a
smiley face on it it's a legitimate sex
education video I just kind of went a
surprise BAM there's some dicks but I
mean what went into deciding to make
that I know the mindset and how you made
it because you just told us that you
were targeting yourself but was it I can
get a lot of views with this was it
there's a legitimate need for sex
education I had no idea if I was getting
a lot of use for it um I thought it
could potentially be a real a real
channel killer and I think and I made
enough redraft to it that it wasn't a
channel killer but it could really have
done a lot of damage if I just been like
oh I'll just I was out in an afternoon
shoot it'll be fine
I went through a lot of different stages
and I actually ran the whole script past
hundreds of people online to be like
what am I saying that's wrong in this
video and luckily I made make loads of
mistakes in the original version so what
was your motive in my in making a
legitimate sex education video t'v I
don't get to doc really but you know the
fact is I was looking up statistics
online and of you know just like
terrible things like sexual abuse and
I'm like wow that's you know one in like
maybe one in three women are sexually
abused and simply it it's not dissimilar
statistics for men but then you know one
in three women are sexually abused and I
look at my own in his audience is
one-third women and two-thirds men and
and I'm thinking you know yeah how many
other people watching my videos right
now are either you know gonna be abused
have been abused will or will be abusers
and I just kind of had this little panic
and I just I had I felt like I had to do
something and Wow and my therapist is
called this a bit of a Messiah Complex
but but no I just felt so much like I
just needed to do something to give
something back more than just just
comedy and and it was and it was it was
great you know I read drafted this video
and and and I think I did a lot of a lot
of good and apparently it's played in
schools now which is really really cool
there was one whole section of the video
which was kind of a how-to which I cut
out and then put on my second channel
because it was like this I don't I don't
need this they don't need this part of
the video well you can figure it out
once you present the part yeah it's like
okay but now gonna make your own
mistakes but web protection my normal or
click to my second change cry like
please don't watch this video I was all
I was so cuz yeah like obviously I'm a
bit kind of the moment and I met this
little group of kids and they couldn't
have been older than five and it was
just like oh oh you've seen that video
they mentioned it they didn't mention it
but they must have seen that video and
it's it's so awful because it's in there
like I like what I write and one thing I
really don't like about YouTube is that
there is an age restriction but it's 18
plus and that's right
whereas I want there to be like a 13
yeah year-old restrict so anyone under
the age of 13 but be YouTube would likes
to pretend that no one under the age of
13 is on their website because that's
obviously why Justin Bieber is the
biggest thing ever is you know no one
under the age of 13 use of YouTube but I
would really wished like an age restrict
that video because while I do think it's
important that younger people see it
especially in this age of the Internet
because if I don't make that video
someone else is gonna they're gonna fall
you're gonna figure it out right well it
was the sex talk video the most unusual
video you ever put on your channel even
in your channel trailer where you kind
of orient people to the fact that you
make three different categories of
videos you make animations you make
action and then you make comedy sketch
videos and you made a comment in there
you said and I'm
to try things so I'm not freaked out
don't freak out and unsubscribe because
I'm gonna experiment and come back with
things that you love that knowing that
the sex talk was not gonna be the only
time I was gonna try something like that
you know I have a few things that I want
to try such as I wanted a video on how
to YouTube for example for a casual just
like who's everything I think you know
people might want to know if they're
going into making YouTube videos but
then I also want to do other videos like
I wanna do a video on you know sexism
but I just kind of want to know
gradually you know be like here's some
company company company company by here
the way here's something that's kind of
important and then what jokes haha I
want to I want to mix things up and I
want to present them in the game the way
that I would have wanted to see them
when I was that age and in a way that
hopefully it's gonna do some good
because the fact is yeah there are loads
of channels doing great things you know
like Laci green you're doing great you
know sexual education videos and other
people doing create social awareness
stuff but the fact is their audience
it's kind of a preaching to the choir
situation their audience is already
there their audience is already
interesting
everybody's going yeah that's your trick
but whereas my audience typically is
like I said your average kind of halo
playing I slept with your mother last
night kids sometimes and sometimes and
and so these are the kind of people it's
pretty insulting you're like I sleep
with your mother sometimes no you know
when you're not even exclusive right
it's just like occasion but you've got
your audience and you've gathered them
around a certain brand of humor across
three different types of videos but then
you're like but I've got things I want
to say to them and I'm not gonna leave
that up to somebody else that's it's
interesting inspiring yeah that's why
the end of my like sex book video I cuz
I never plan I make another one because
I feel like I'll do more videos like the
on sex and like no that's fine but
that's why the end of it I was like I'm
gonna link to Laci green Laci take it
from here uh-huh and just yet just
hopefully she got like a nice influx of
kids being like what does this button do
we haven't talked about violence I mean
that's a big part of yes even across
genres mm-hmm
I don't know if it's in the sex talk
suicide it's awful I mean people may
just casually look at your work and said
well that's why that's why so successful
again we we know better but what what
how do you view it and and how do you
bake in violence what's your what's your
thought processes there
I love violence as a comedic tool I just
I love explosions blood and mic yeah and
and stuff like that Mike my goal is to
one day flip a car you know I've been
going when I was younger I was raised
quite religious but even you know in
charge I was still making guns out of
plasticine and getting them confiscated
and drawing stickmen you know blowing up
and that's just always been a part of me
when I when I was about 8 years old my
mum would every week buy me a pack of
toy cars which I would take to the
garden and destroy with a shovel a
shovel and I would do this every week
and like hakkim yeah just smash them
just break him pretend they're crashing
and just I've just been always been a
very destructive child but it was like
basically I'm saying and I'm kind of
like dexta whereas I had these
tendencies but my parents just kind of
let me hone them in and in it they just
they kind of just like let me control
them and now that now I make them on
YouTube but yeah I think some peer not
like horse from that video you just
really know that video that video was
the darkest the weirdest thing I've ever
made when I explained it okay I have
this one character where and it's me
wearing a horse mask running around in a
dress murdering people and that's oddly
enough that's one of the least
problematic videos I think I've ever
made that video is just very much like
it doesn't come from a dark place it's
just I find it very funny and it seems
very happy because of the music the
music is it's a creepy horse mask you'll
ever see which floats around the
internet we own one
no we ghosts they're so funny but um
yeah what's funny is the midway through
shooting that video I had a therapy
appointment so midway through shooting
that video I got in the cab went to
therapy with the Taurus and horse
head-on not with the horse Muslim but
then I came I came back and reviewed
shooting that video and it was it miss a
beat didn't miss a single beat well yeah
how much you pay in this therapist but
yes a lot well she's not doing it he's
like oh and you know what you should
just continue to this take the knife
with you and just get out whatever you
in my office he's terrifying man well
let's get let's go back to the back
story then I mean the crashing cars kid
who eventually makes murderous horse
videos where was this where were you
born we know how you were made you made
the video about it oh yes absolutely
so we can skip that part yeah I wish my
parents didn't tell me isn't in such
excruciating detail my backstory visit
no we're not gonna start could ever
visit Scotland or Loch Ness now but but
yeah no I was you know I was born and
raised in England I was a born I say
born and raised I'm still there except
about now I was born in Essex actually
so my actual original action is more is
which is so Essex is kind of like what I
want to say scummy but you know it's
bill maybe you're like youtubers like
sarin pepper and stuff like that so Emma
blackery as well that's that's the Essex
accent okay I grew out of that when I
was about six we moved to Cambridge
which is actually a very posh part of
England you know Cambridge University
they they they wrote boats against
Oxford a lot there's a pretty incredible
story of your birth right
oh yeah no yeah it's wild so I was
originally a twin I I had a twin sister
named Amelia at this point I was named
Dudley which is fabulous Len Dudley yeah
full on Harry Potter style and as a
chubby kid they would have been hell at
school that would have been like the
worst yeah the worst ever of my life
always I've never I have never met a
real Dudley and it's like I would've
been the only one no solidarity would
just been me I wouldn't be popular on
YouTube like I didn't even like the name
Thomas when I started making you know
online videos but now I'm like why
that's stupid but if I'd been called
Dudley I think I would never would have
gotten over there but but yeah no but
basically my mum my mother had a car
accident coz some stupid person pulled
out in front of her and caused her to an
emergency brake and and sadly my mother
lost my sister in this axon accident and
this is why she was pregnant with me she
was pregnant and and the doctor said
like oh you know the child's gone I'm
sorry you don't have children now
and my mom you know went back to work
for a couple months and was like no I
think I'm pregnant the doctors like no
no they did baby's dead
she's like I'm pretty sure I'm pregnant
and then they finally caved in and did a
check and like there's a Dudley in there
there's a mmm well yeah there is a
Dudley in there and then my mom was like
hey Tom's dad you know how I had a child
died I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna pull
rank and I'm gonna be like I need a
favor and it's to not call my child
Dudley cuz that's awful and I got
luckily named Thomas but yeah then my
mom had to like you know just sleep with
like she had to like basically lay down
and this is so disturbingly graphic but
because I basically would have fallen
out
I was so complicated and and I was born
about a month premature you know in a
little box lived in she did she carry
your twin as well no no the the twin was
lost kind of immediately after the crash
but the twin basically is the reason I'm
alive
she took physically the impact of the
crash it's oh wow yeah it's quite
graphic to imagine but hey so that's
really weird but I get my files my plan
is if I have a daughter I'm there's no
question like she's named Amelia there's
like just no question about right
what this future what if was this a
story you knew from a young age or
something that you found out later in
life I kind of know it from a young age
so your parents were open about kind of
talking about those type of things it
really hit me what it meant until quite
later in life I was thinking as much but
about 16 or something like oh I'm
supposed to be a twin that's weird you
know that really kind of you know
weirded me out especially the etymology
of our names
well the story about like as like Thomas
actually means twin which is weird and
Amelia comes from the Latin I belief of
ameliorate which means to make better so
basically I was totally the evil twin
well mm which is fine I mean it's kind
of obvious but yeah that's um that's
kind of a weird little backstory B I was
B I was born and raised and we moved to
Cambridge and what did your parents do
my so my mom runs a hairdressing salon
well that's like extreme backup job
clearly and and my dad co-owns the
family business of landscape gardening
so basically I'm moving very soon and
I'm having my dad come and do my garden
I'm hiring my father which is the
strangest experience but yeah that's my
backup plan is is the family landscape
gardening business now you said you grew
up Jehovah's Witness yeah
so the were they devout devout Jehovah's
Witnesses are they still and what's it
like growing up in in that it's
difficult to speak on their behalf so I
warrant but yeah I was I was raised at
least for the first few years a devout
Jehovah's Witness
you know full-on knocking on the doors
kind of upbringing no birthdays no no no
Christmases and and all that stuff and
and then and what's left over now is
even though that's not me anymore I
actually have a lot of I have I have a
lot of love for the people in my life
but I have a lot of disdain for
organized religion as a whole but you
know I would I wouldn't I don't really
want to inflict that on anyone maybe a
video will come out of it one day but
for now I'm okay just to let that
sleeping dog lie
what was the progression I mean the
progression was was really just a we
kind of slipped away I think the whole
family kind of pulled back a bit over
time and then like I spent my first 10
years very carefully indoctrinated into
that but not enough that I became kind
of brainwashed but then you know we kind
of fell back for a few years and then I
taught my parents tried to get me more
back into it I'd already kind of slipped
in there and then I went to uni and
started meeting atheists and people from
the world and and I came and and I kind
of became very open-minded and and was
there anyone in particular or any thing
or that happened that kind of broke you
out of the faith there's a handful of a
handful of things actually one of them
is my friend Jacob who was a youtuber
called Layton way and meeting him he was
like an atheist ranty youtuber and
meeting him and becoming friends with
him I think definitely shaped me a lot
but anyway when I was younger one of the
most formative moments in my life was I
could've been older than about 18 and I
was waiting in town centre to hang out
with my college friends then there was
this this this man this a you know
Jellicle christian fellow on a literal
soapbox you know preaching to the crowd
and he was he was killer it was so
impressive to watch even if I didn't
necessarily agree with everything he was
saying I was still you know kind of
religious and he was just amazing like
people were coming up to him asking him
impossible questions like so two babies
go to hell and and and so and crazy
questions that like would stomp anyone
and this man would still take them who
say get a baby in and it was incredible
and at the end of it I walked over to
him I was like hey man I just like want
to say even I don't necessarily agree
with everything you said that well
you're an incredible public speaker you
know like Hitler and he was very polite
and I said you know and then I said you
know but I don't necessarily kind of you
know I don't necessary agree with
everything you said he's like oh well
you know that's okay man and then when
you know I was I'm actually raised a
Jehovah's Witness and then this man's
face just turned and he just got and
they went well brother with a big smile
on his face man well brother you're
going to help you're gonna burn in hell
realize yeah just with this this
terrifying you know smile on his face
just this of this you know fold love and
I was like well you need your soul to be
saved and stuff like this and the fact
that he could say that to me you know
but also still feel like he means well
and and genuinely believe that just made
me so terrified and angry towards you
know religion that was kind of a very
much a tipping point and being like oh
okay this is off maybe maybe that maybe
there maybe there is no right way and
and that's kind of what actually made to
become more open mind and then I wrote a
vlog called the day my faith died about
this this moment and and I never really
made it because I don't want to start
that conversation yet I don't really
have any answers I never really will I I
guess I got the moment I die clamp I
lost myself us at agnostic which is just
young em is their God and so you wrote a
vlog you scripted it but you never
filmed it no because you don't want to
have that dialog on your channel yeah
yeah it's just like all the things I
want to stand for at the moment that's
not one of them I don't really have
anything to say yet you know I feel like
well well I mean it's already quite it's
already quite you know out of line in a
way of me to give my audience the sex
talk I took a million children maybe
that who
whose parents had maybe even decided not
to tell their kids about this yet and
gave them the sexually prematurely an
and so I can understand wait as a parent
you'd be very upset about that and so if
I'm gonna be like hey maybe religions
kind of crappy that's not that's just
not my place yet unless I get something
that's really a unless I have something
that's really powerful to say but no I
know I feel this kind of a because it's
true that I'm still a bit angry and I
kind of want to be coming from a place
of actual understanding and well you
know it seems like even if that's what
you've gone through personally from what
I can see you you you don't bring that
particular thing into your comedy you
don't make fun of I have I have two
rules to rules when I started making
YouTube which I still adhere to and that
is no swearing and no blasphemy for some
reason and I guess I guess when I
started it was always because you know
it's making the question that was you
know would I be I kept my parents
watching this and that was it or would
more so would I be okay with my parents
friends watching this the parents from
the religion and that write those
bridges along burned now long burned but
still there was a and you stuck with
that yeah I still I still don't swear
because I actually kind of liked the
challenge of making comedy without swear
words I don't think it makes me better
than anyone in any way but I like do
like the challenge and it does make it
harder it doesn't make some drugs not
funny sometimes I've replaced the f-word
with screw or something and it's just
not as funny right but it is because you
know I do want my comedy to be
accessible to little younglings and and
while I think it's okay for kids to know
swear words just I don't know I just
like I do have a bit of a problem with
with with comp with swearing in comedy
sometimes and a lot of the bit the
bigger you know the like a crutch the
bigger youtubers yeah like sometimes I
just I feel like your joke was literally
that someone just swore there was no
mm-hmm that's not a joke there's no
artistry to there this is just a shock
and anything and I've tweet tweet about
that yeah I still I still have to keep
and check my tweeting habits it's awful
because the rule of drive line the
Internet is anything you say about
someone can and will be found and read
by them I held against you and the first
VidCon I went to back in 2012 I just I
ran into the guys who make dick Figures
yeah and after after I tweeted you know
like about
doing a Kickstarter and how much money
they'd asked for and and then and they'd
remember that and everyone in their
office already knew who I was and I was
like I can't say mean things anymore
such and yeah and like they're like
lately I actually did a tweet cuz you
know obviously PewDiePie biggest
youtuber in the world at the moment and
I don't know anything about him but you
know because that big youtubers you
dehumanize them you just tell yourself
like oh they're just a big youtuber yeah
mmm but I was like I actually asked my
audience I was like is he what is
PewDiePie is he actually a nice guy and
um I was like yeah actually done it's
like hundreds of thousands to charity
and I'm like oh that's really cool and
then he messaged me like I'm a nice guy
in your audience is he nice personally
nice Felix is a lot like me which is
that he's will track down anything and
everything said about him when when we
you know we have the tag you know of our
name saved on tumblr on Twitter it's not
because we're looking for compliments
for some reason we're morbidly looking
for that one person who said like I hate
this person so we can reply going why
what's the worst thing that you singh's
been said about you and did you did you
engage I have a awful habit of engaging
I have a lot of people who don't like me
and most of it's quite fair I was quite
abrasive when I was younger and that's
left scars I di I there's a small clique
of people online that are very ready to
call me out whenever I slip up in any
way what do you like The Devil's on my
shoulder at basically any insecurity I
have they will echo it very loudly and
so basically if they if they're ok with
something I've done that I know that it
must be alright but yeah that's there's
critics there's a lot of critics
especially when you ESPE especially when
you know what you make is so you know
outward least simple and it gets the
interviews a lot of people feel
threatened by big successful YouTube
videos people forget that actually the
more popular a YouTube video is it means
that there's actually more traffic on
the site and more chance for you to
succeed right I genuinely believe that
so that you should never be threatened
by another youtuber you should never
look at someone who's made sketch-comedy
and it's got a million views and be like
oh well now no one's gonna see my sketch
it's not like it's not like that it
isn't like a cinema screening and
there's one screening and then they've
now missed you it's mm-hmm there's
actually more likely that you will see
but now you got involved in creating
things comedic animations and I kind of
think I really early right I mean how
old are we talking about 10 I'd say so I
back at the turn of the millennium so
how did that happen
so I was back in the old days of the
internet before Google was really a
thing and all that stuff as I'm sure you
know the way we found websites was we
would type in we would write a word and
then put calm at the end and when you're
9 10 years old that that goes as far as
typing and words like fart calm
watts calm and my father thought I was
searching porn when I was younger
because I would search rude words
ted.com and he was like oh what are you
doing you deviant it's like no I just
it's a funny word I just need to go to
fart kind I mean he was calm what was it
fart sky I couldn't tell you but I'm
sure it's still active well that part's
calm right now I'm gonna check I feel
like there's a good way to get a virus
once it farts come it's it seems to be
anything that's available that's not
true it's it's definitely parked like
it's running I'm sure cost you like
10,000 oh well I'm interested
researching things like you know I went
to stupid calm okay and I saw this
animation called Maynard by a fellow
called Tom des long Chomp who is this
American artist fellow and and it was
just just terrible it's a stupid little
animation of this man with a deformed
head I think riding a skateboard and
laughing it's girls and but in that
moment you know it must have been only
one I've been about 10 years old and I
said you that whatever this is I'm gonna
do this for the rest of my life this is
what I want to be and this this website
is still up
it's amazing sounds like knickknacks and
things and it's still much the same I
think it's in the same redneck farting
but neck pillow no equal 16.99
the intelligence owner would do the
motor people of this site has not
changed in the slightest but it's not
animation anymore button and when you
saw that though what was the when you
said I want to do this why why did you
want to do
I never thought like I want to make
movies I want to make TV I thought I
don't know what this is but I'm sitting
on a computer I'm watching a cartoon
character if fall over on a skateboard
I'm gonna do this whatever this is I'm
gonna do it for the rest of my life and
that day was the day I started lying to
animate and I didn't know what how kids
animated so I thought you animated in
PowerPoint Microsoft PowerPoint so I
would make if she's fly exactly slide in
slides of PowerPoint and it'll be like a
do circle on one slide then move on the
next slide you know no like hit spacebar
we did this do you not remember this we
did the same thing with that
presentation software at school that
wasn't PowerPoint but was on the the
high school computers I totally remember
doing this there but you would do just a
few frames and every time you hit the
spacebar is something would change yeah
or the arrow key how you do it and then
I make things like had hundreds of
frames until it crashed the you know
school computers but eventually I
learned although way people use flash
and and I grew at that and I grew and
grew and grew and then I was about 16 17
18 then I was like oh this I'm gonna
hire people and heard this little
twelve-year-old kid came up to me and
was like hey
TomSka I have 5,000 more subscribers
than you on YouTube because I had to
thousands kids at 8,000 and he said
let's collaborate and I said okay well
can you kind of make this asked of movie
thing for my channel and boom that was
the first on yeah that was the first
time I ever like you know produced or
hired someone she's hired animation you
were 16 I was 18 or just an 18 and this
kid was 12 13 I think it was 13 and you
know he was a bigger youtuber than me
like I had like I said I had two
thousand subscribers and he just did it
for free and because like I hoped he
would be successful I had no idea really
what would happen and then a few months
later I felt bad so I gave him 20 pounds
which is about $35 I was like I feel
really bad so I gave him a hundred
pounds the other ones no he did not
but yeah that was that was kind of how
it kicked off and that first one how
quickly did it take off and was that all
on YouTube or was yeah that was that was
all YouTube
yeah the first ask to movie you know
it's uploaded August 10th 2008 and you
know it immediately did pretty well like
it was like got like 40,000 views in its
first day and then you know kind of next
month went up to 700,000 views and then
I'm at a month later it broke a million
if I was if you tried before then I just
tried little sketches you know little
things I would make to make stuff at
school you know whenever I did like a
meteor and then film Holly and I mean
she's not know how to make snow
live-action III did I did I did live
action
I was a couple animations and they were
just awful I have an animation called
Pokemon extreme which kind of is is the
highlight of my animating capabilities
it's waffle and yeah and that just that
just I really really took off and now
has like 15 million views and that's
weird
to think oh well every single yeah one
of those has that at this point which is
just strange and terrifying it's such an
it's such a terrifying number to imagine
like you know like I come to here like
VidCon it's like oh 16,000 people that's
a lot of people if a video I made got
that in at that in a day I'd be like
well this is the worst failure I've ever
made yeah so you were an adopter of
internet Ament really before there was
YouTube you were putting stuff on Smosh
comments stupid calm and everywhere else
you can find it I remember when it was
Google Video and I mean now is Google
video again but still right yeah so you
were living it you were living at home
up until the age of 18 and just kind of
doing this for fun at some what did you
do after 18 I went to university like I
already kind of figured that I didn't
really care about university I just
wanted to do this and that took me but I
went to university and I still got my
degree but really it was what I did that
was mostly grow as a youtuber okay and
you know I've never had to use my degree
to get a job I had to turn down jobs
whilst at university well tell us about
the minsum thing oh the Mensa thing oh
goodness I mean that was that's like
yeah like that's a really weird thing
that I just didn't pretty much never
talked about that because it's much like
talking about religion for some reason
it starts a fight every time I do
because they're ones like oh you figured
genius was like no I don't like it I
have a piece of paper leave me alone so
but when I was nine years old I I went a
bit loopy because I had a teacher that
was bullying me and
that they are the just how so emotional
like you know torment you know being
like oh I'm gonna make this one child
because I was a fidgeter I was a
nuisance but parents teacher was very
abusive and since since then has
actually been like fired and like sued
and I believe in all this stuff but but
like you know you're like make like when
in the assembly or whatever it's called
here you know when it's all the kids in
the room like she just make me stand up
all like she'd bring me to the front and
do start over put my hands in my pockets
should pin the pockets but basically you
know just really awful teacher but I
went a bit loopy and II just couldn't
figure out why and that's actually where
I developed an eating problem cake is
just delicious only to IHOP today oh my
International House pancakes is a big
lie though it's only here in America
anyway so it draws an international
crowd it really really really really
does um so as a coping mechanism you
would start eating would start coming a
genius not so much but they they took me
to the shrink and the shrink was like
hey there's something strange about this
kid we think he has Asperger's and then
he took me to do an IQ test like oh we
were wrong no he actually has a
genius-level IQ and I can't say that I
can't speak for what I have now but when
I was nine I had a genius-level IQ and
and they will be in münster and that was
just a nice little thing what is it I
don't know what explain that after
commencer is just a I'm sure it stands
for something but it's a just an
honorary title for smart people and just
you have to go to meetings no everyone
mentor is short-sighted turn your head
no you didn't work when you say hi my
name is Tom and I am a genius never
really hasn't really had any effect on
my life but um yeah everyone hoots like
in it is some kind of like scientist or
something and I'm like I'm gonna make
cartoons online but people do get your
what you're getting at - as people are
really sensitive about anytime you say
anything about yourself yeah immediately
compare that you any pride you're like
I'm gonna destroy you so it is it's not
the British Way you know the British way
you have to you know be like hey I'm and
then they love so I just don't really
mention the good things I don't really
reply to the nice people or talk about
the good stuff because when I do it just
seeing people are like oh look at you
boasting about you face
so this job keeps you humble yeah it
depending on what you read and you just
have to read it all I know how it is so
at uni as you call it University you
were still very much focused on YouTube
is what she said yeah as a business
model kind of it yeah it was very
fortunately yeah the YouTube Partner
Program came in just as I turned 18 near
enough and that meant that I never had
to get a real job I'm doing air quotes
you can't see but I never had to get a
real job so luckily I just started
making a living off that and in my first
year university I got to tell my parents
you know what I don't need my pocket
money this this month I cut this okay
well tell us about eddsworld and how
that comes in all this okay so as well
um back in the old Smosh calm days
there's a website called stick suicide
which actually is now cyanide and
Happiness the the very popular web comic
but it was stick suicide where I met at
this kid called EDD Gould who was this
you know some reason very physically
underdeveloped man he was about 15 years
old his voice didn't break so his 18
which is very questionable how and he
was 15 he was a couple years older than
me so I've got like 13 hear them in
about 15 and and he made these just
awful looking back now animations but
you know I as a kid who loved online
cartoons I was like you are God and I
spammed him and I spammed him until
eventually he was like okay you can hear
in the background of one of my really
good cartoons and then you know and then
as time went by it was like okay you can
do a voice okay yo character has a name
and then there this show grew and over
the course of you know nearly eight
years the show eddsworld grew and became
this kind of big thing that the people
really really loved and it's just this
is this cartoon series about you know ed
and and Tom and and his friend man and
the wacky adventures that these you know
three straight white males get on in
your table I was Tom and it was kind of
a longer form mmm yeah like they were
always about 10 minutes because Edie had
awful pacing and what could've been five
minutes was always about ten just lots
of pause if he'd spent a long time
drawing a background he we had to make
sure everyone saw it but you know it's
sad
he develops near cancer of the blood
leukemia and passed away in 2012 I mean
but you were there from a 13 year old
going through this whole process with
them I mean I actually what's really
funny is funny actually this is the
saddest thing I want to say what's
really sad is you know I compared you
know our relationship to your guys
relationship you know when when he
passed I was like well great I am you
know I'm linked without my Rhett or
Brett without my link whichever I owe
you know or other YouTube you know duos
I mean without Anthony John without Hank
right I mean let's see wins without
beretta
oh wait that happened to play well let's
build into it a little bit more up to
that point I mean you guys are you
working remotely you didn't yeah he
lived in London I was you know I was
around in different places we would hang
out here and there but you know
ultimately we made the cartoon online
and how successful was it it was you
know it was pretty successful it's got a
really it's held a really weird place in
a lot of people's hearts it's a source
of nostalgia and inspiration for a lot
of people and that's that's wicked nice
and and saying you were doing your own
videos yeah it was parallel I was doing
my own things but they were always
smaller than Ed's I only overtook him in
subscribers when he had cancer which
didn't really feel like a fair game it
was like he was told us in the hair it
was like oh come on at least get up on
your feet soldier so your main thing was
being yeah I think the most impressive
thing I did with it was Ed's world which
I gradually kind of took over as a
co-writer co-producer co-director and
and stuff and and by the time that
before had passed I'd already kind of
moved on to being the lead you know
writer and director and producer and and
you've said online that Ed was
instrumental it being the kind of the
first critic of your oh yeah miserable
bugger like he would yeah anything you
presented him with he'd be the first to
criticize it he hated ass to movie
despite animating animating the most
popular one and playing the most popular
character the I like trains kid and what
was his criticism same as everyone
else's same as all the other animators
in the world just like it's really
simple and it's not very funny but you
know this is that said he was a
miserable man that's what
part of his charm right looking at
quotes again and you became business
partners working remotely were you also
best friends best friends is a very
strong what I say his best friend was a
fella called mat or Baldy cube mat
lobster whatever username he's going by
at the moment and and yet there they
were definitely best friend because they
know that they lived together at uni and
they'd put in friends for a very long
time but the thing was I moved down to
London in 2011 to live with Ed and to
like now and finished university finally
now I'm gonna move to London I'm gonna
be your best friend we're gonna live
together and we're gonna take this show
on the road yeah and then he died he had
leukemia and then there was a remission
he had leukemia when he was younger and
the problem you know with leukemia and
before you met him he had developed it
and yeah and the horrible thing about in
a battle is that when you know when it
went away
the doctors didn't tell him like oh it's
gone it's it was more of a well it it'll
come back and yeah it's not a matter of
will it kill you it's when it'll kill
you with with hit with his diagnosis
which was awful but he but yeah he was
on track to be there which is really
weird the doctors like yeah a 70/30
chance he'll live
nope and that was really awful but yeah
when he passed I and how much did you
talk about it I mean was it a very
kindly like that's the thing is that I
never once I I tried to be very strong I
never once played into the like the sad
you know like Oh buddy how you doing you
know I would every time I visit him in
the hospital first thing I pretty much
say what happened and I just make jokes
immediately and then he was always be so
sad in the hospital you know because
like either his parents or someone be
there being very heavy sad mm-hmm and
I'd show up and I'd feel like get out of
bed and and I think that was that was
very helpful to to him to have someone
who you know just treated it like it was
normal like because that he truly just
kind of felt it as an inconvenience you
know it stopped him from making cartoons
which he wanted to do and so I you know
I was stable but I didn't altum Utley I
didn't emotionally prepare myself in any
way for the chance that I was wrong so I
was in denial for quite a while when he
passed was there a struggle and having
left the faith that you were raised in
at this point you know
the rubber meets the road was there a an
increased bitterness of that or a
temptation to go back to it or did you
hi how did your thankful I guess I was
just very kind of I didn't blame anyone
like the last thing is you know like
kind of its oddly freeing to be like
well there's no one to blame it's just
it is you know happens and and it was
you know but then but then yes a java's
witness did knock on my door a few weeks
later I was like hey I wanna have booked
and I'm like brother just don't and you
know because yeah but yeah was very hard
to get you know because the first time I
had got cancer I don't know how and what
you want this in your podcast but the
first time I did get cancer I blamed
myself realize of religious upbringing
and this is we connect those dots I
don't get it
yep this is a fun story and this is a
whole vlogs worth of content I'm just
gonna pile into you know one sentence by
okay did just let have it so I think
there's another reason why I definitely
felt like I needed to make the sex talk
was because of my religious background I
genuinely believed when I was a child
that masturbation was such a sin that it
caused bad things to happen and every
time I did it something bad would happen
and be my fault
so Edie went to the doctors and you know
they were like oh you might have cancer
and he told me on MSN those were the
days and I was like oh no no I sure have
been doing that a lot maybe it's my
fault
I really shouldn't touch my I'm gonna do
it and then the next day it was like oh
well I have cancer and I felt alright
guilty and so responsible we don't have
the results yet yeah well no the next
day and I was like well I really
shouldn't tempt fate but I am 14 and and
yeah and I felt sure I felt responsible
and I prayed and prayed and prayed and I
you know I made it I struck I struck up
a deal with God and I said I will not
touch myself if ever again if Ed gets to
live and I didn't for two years until
cancer went into remission
and did you kinda went back on my deal
but you felt when you when it went into
remission did you feel like that you had
paid your penance and away I kind of
yeah like it's very arrogant to believe
like oh yeah I lived his life but I know
it was yeah I felt it was well not
happening you caused it I felt like I
caused it and so I was like I'm sorry
I'll never do that again but and I did
that again but yeah that was that was
very strange and these are other reasons
why I need needed to make the sex talk
and write and tell people to touch
themselves and it's not weird and it
doesn't give people cancer and kill your
cat and then how long until return three
years I'd say so you know basically the
entirety of me being at Union it was
just when I'd finish uni and I was
planning the move where it's pretty much
like oh it's back at that point you're
you had relinquished your faith yeah
well yeah I kind of just been like yeah
this isn't for me
and then stuff so so there was no
struggle when it came back for there to
be a personal driving you I wasn't I
wasn't like okay I did it again sorry
girlfriend you're out but I actually did
break up my girlfriend around about that
time but I was different reasons yeah no
there wasn't there wasn't a a religious
struggle there it was just kind of like
a I was definitely a more than mindset
of you know not everything happens for a
reason you mentioned it in a vlog that
you kind of took it upon yourself to
continue eddsworld tell us about how
that came about
that was a hasty decision so you know
what's what's really most about the
situation is that the day had died or
the day before had died I was joking
around with with Paul who would become
the animator of the show the you know
like oh here's what I'm gonna do if it
ever gets like a terminal diagnosis it's
like just joking around you know it
because other thing is that we played it
like we played like oh it's never gonna
happen let's make it a source of comedy
and I was like saying like oh would be
like you know like chef from South Park
with uh we'd record loads of extra lines
and then just still keep the show going
and all this stuff and like seven hours
later ed was dead so it was it was very
sudden it was so sudden like the the
doctors like it was just like he was ill
but
then suddenly everything has failed in
the space of hours and I was asleep when
it all happened I I woke up to the phone
call which was bizarre but I had talked
to Ed briefly about we know what would
happen if he died but it's not like the
kind of conversation if you croak it
what am I gonna do with that show but
you know Ed's mum's told me the you know
before he died he'd said that he wanted
me to continue the show and I just have
to kind of take her word on it hope she
wasn't lying but the way I went about it
I regret massively though III know I
know YouTube and I know commenters and I
was really afraid that if I kept the
show going people would be like oh
you're profiting off Ed's death so I
said I won't give everything the show
makes to charity but I think the only
way I can do that as if I ask people if
I if I did a fundraiser to fund the show
and the support was amazing you know we
raised eighty three thousand dollars I
believe and that was crazy
um wish I hadn't done that I wish that I
had actually either paid for the show
out of its own profits because we still
would have donated a lot of charity all
paid for it myself because I'd say to
say that I'd say that the amount of
money I've lost from the stress of that
obligation has been greater than the
savings of not paying for it myself and
suddenly become making into an
obligation was terrifying and just not
something that I think we should have
done they turned it into a job rather
than an honoring of a friendship and
internal obligation so we still have a
lot to do we know we have like four and
a bit more episodes to go before we've
met those obligations but yeah that was
before you've met the obligations that
you promised and of the initial go
campaign yeah and how long after he what
he died in well he died in early 2012
and here we are in mid 2014 that's still
we're still not done like we really
thought like oh it'll take us a year no
you know that that was very wishful
thinking and yeah we made promises that
we couldn't keep and that was dumb in
retrospect do you believe that this is
still honoring his memory and your
friendship I absolutely do I think it's
honoring his memory it's friendship for
the wrong reasons now it's because
they're like I said it'd be kind of
obligation of obligation not out of you
know love I think that it would have
been it would have done a lot better and
people would have worked you know people
would probably work for free if money
hadn't even got involved
people would have done it for love we
could run at her own pace and and maybe
stopped whenever we wanted to but how
does it end I mean do you know how it's
gonna end because I think a lot of
question is well does the character pass
away is there some so we have two
episodes two big episodes planned called
the end part 1 and part 2 which are
these massive fun episodes where we're
gonna try and tie up a lot of narratives
not and and not with the intention of
ending the show per se but just bringing
it to a satisfactory point where if we
didn't continue no one's gonna be going
but what happened you know we have plans
and and maybe maybe once we have
finished it suddenly we'll feel free and
like Oh actually I do want to keep going
but we're giving ourselves the option to
maybe go like okay we did it and we keep
we can't keep doing this it's it
ultimately it isn't our show it was his
show and we need to move on with our
lives but we're giving ourselves the
option but maybe we weren't then was the
conversation with its mom like about
this at this point it's very strange
she's a little big fan of the show but
yeah I mean I think it is she yeah like
I haven't definitively and I probably
haven't offensively told her that you
know like oh yeah by the way we're gonna
end the show because the fact is we
don't know but she would understand at
this point I think she wouldn't be like
oh well it sounds like there's lots of
lessons that you've learned specifically
related to that but overall in this
whole experience of losing a business
partner a creative collaborator and a
close friend I mean what's your
perspective on that and what you've
learned and how how does that impact how
you live your life it's changed
absolutely everything really I'm you
know I mean can you guys imagine it
without the other of you it would just
be well I just spent a lifetime building
up a thing with this person that's done
now so it's just kind of it's there is
no point to it there's and that's what I
hate about as a storyteller as it as a
film lover there's no twist there's no
no there's no point to this this is just
chaos it's just it's just happened and
the any replaceable part of my life is
gone and it's like a South Korean movie
you ever seen the South Korean movie
they always end so sad I haven't I'm not
interested at this point hey that's like
that's how they always like it film like
the host and it's just oh okay well I
was all for nothing
but it's interesting you say as a
filmmaker maybe it's as a human we want
our lives and certainly the tragedies
and the heartache to be redeemed with
meaning the only thing I've really truly
learned from losing it edie is the
importance of legacy I guess then this
sounds very pretentious but I guess if
anything I feel like I've had an insight
into the meaning of life which and in my
opinion it is a legacy it's what we
leave behind it's the amount of people
that we touch and an effect and and yeah
and and inspire and when I'd passed what
came out of the woodwork was the
thousands and thousands of people that
he had brought joy to and inspired to
become animators and and that was in
that was incredible and I think I
decided that point that what I care the
most about is my legacy is how many
people I can inspire and how much good I
can do and how much joy I can bring to
the world I mean that mostly on YouTube
in real life I'm quite a you know
contemptuous person but online at least
two strangers I'd like to bring joy and
I want it you know I want to do good and
I want to make videos like the sex talk
and I want to do videos you know I
wanted to a video on you know on
self-harm and help people and affect
people and and do good and leave behind
a legacy because you know it will it
does have a ripple effect and it will
pass through time it's not just you know
like without YouTube I would be able to
only affect my you know my friends and
my immediate family and and that's a few
generations and then maybe that's all
gone but hopefully you know I can change
things and make people happy you know
that's that's what I at least believe is
the point of my life but at the end of
your heart-wrenching vlog where you
processed Ed's death the last thing you
said was I could say I may be getting
this wrong but you said something to the
effect of I could say that I don't know
what I'm gonna do where I go from here
but the truth is I do
um and it's just what it'd be as fun
anymore and it's not gonna be as fun
anymore
yeah as you know in the last couple of
years a has that proven to be true have
things have you found the ability to
have fun more than you thought and what
is it that you know you're doing without
him yeah well you know like uh so if you
really if you watch mate if you watch
the numbers if you watch my channel
right around the point that I'd died I
had like a bunch of videos written and
it was actually the summer of kind of
like my but the best content on my
channel of my successful stuff videos
I'd made and you know but then as soon
as I had to start making things after
he'd passed I did I did just like
massively fall off and sank into a big
hole for at least two years which I am
now I can comfortably say now I'm
getting out of and yeah that yeah I do I
do know what I'm doing but it isn't as
finally more it did cost me about you
know two years of my life like I still
made videos and I made a lot I think I
made a lot of really good videos but I
you know like it did really stick a
thorn in everything and and that was
lame but yeah it's getting better it's
getting a lot better and I'm starting to
actually enjoy my job again for the
first time in a while I'm excited to do
things and that's killer
for me like I haven't been the video
like I was getting a bit sad before I
died and I just kind of like feeling
like this is just my job and my hobby is
gone it's just the obligation now and
but like now I'm finally feeling that
love again and I'm feeling excited again
which is really great it's just at the
point when the numbers are getting awful
on YouTube and I'm really struggling to
like maintain my audience but maybe now
I'm gonna have that excitement that love
that I need to bring it back you know
all the people can get you know ten
million views on every video they make
than damage so can i I'm coming back
this is 2014 let's go we won't hold you
up anymore you got to get back to right
in that next video I have I've actually
load on the plane over here which is
which is great and very exciting well
listen we are you know you're we love
everything that you've done and this
time just hanging out with you has been
it's been fun so thank you thank you so
much for having me like it you know like
yeah we're like when I came in this room
the first thing I did was I brought up
laptops and checked and and yeah I've
been falling here since 2007 and then
it's it's really really means a lot to
beyond me you guys it's it's wicked
thank you so much for everything you do
as well
yeah no applause for you that's silent
silent I got an impost okay well we
don't do that but you know what we can't
in spirit
thanks Thomas TomSka thank you and there
you have it our ear biscuit with Tom
Scott
incredibly thoughtful guy and I don't
mean like the thoughtful guy song that
we wrote a guy just thinks about a lot
of weird stuff I mean a thoughtful guy
who has been through a lot of things and
is processing and has processed a lot of
things that you mayn't you just don't
know that you just can't look at
somebody's YouTube channel especially
somebody who's such an artist as him is
making sketch videos and animations and
know just how much has transpired over
the past few years yeah and I mean so
I'm truly appreciative of his his
honesty I think it you know I certainly
have many takeaways and things that I
continue to think about from that
conversation I'm sure you do too let Tom
know what you think on Twitter his
Twitter handle is V Tom Scavo
Tom Scott I don't care how you pronounce
that that's how you say it you know the
guy's been through the wringer he's
coming out on the other side of it where
he can be excited about being creative
and I'm excited you know I love every
conversation we have on your biscuits
but there are the certain people that we
talk to that I get especially excited
about what they have yet to do and when
you talk to a guy like Tom you see the
work that he's done I'm excited about
this guy's he's young he's got so much
stuff that he's gonna create I'm I've
loved everything that he's done I'm
excited about what he's going to do in
the future
yeah so thanks Tom you can again tweet
at him the TomSka and also hash tag ear
biscuits to let us know what you think
of this show
leave a review on iTunes that's always
helpful and you can count on us to be
here next week for another one of these
yes indeed
[Music]
[Music]